[pain]
Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier....
...and welcome to another Impossible Let's Play!
For today's challenge...
...I will be taking this electroshock-game...
...and playing it by myself...
...while I'm trying to complete...
...Don't Let Go for the Oculus Rift.
It's gonna be great! [laughs]
All right, let's do this!
This gonna be FUUUUN!
[pain laugh]
Oh-okay.
It works.
Okay, I'm ready to get started. Let's do this!
OW - why do I do this to myself?! Let's go!
Hello!
First shock... Go!
AAAH - okay, it didn't...
... it didn't do it the first time I pressed it.
Hello bees, my old friend.
Still not sure if you're... if you're bees or FLIIIES...
That is tingly!
AH, that's tingly!
Oh, my Oculus Rift is already drifting upwards!
HELLO!
HOW ARE YOU DOING TODAY?
Ookay... ow-ow.
[laughs]
AH - it's the worst on the left hand!
I dunno why!
It's so much worse on the left hand.
It's like I got better contact on it or something.
UGH! Again!
AAAAH-okay!
Okay.
Ahhh, okay.
This doesn't...[pain]
I forgot about you. You get out of there.
Oh.
OH HEY!
Hello Dino, my old friend!
It's good to see you agaaaain!
How are you doing?
You wanna come over and gimme a big lick?
Why don't you lick this device down here...
...then we can reaaally get this party started!
[pain laugh]
I wonder if you can see my muscles twitching over there.
Like... OOAAAH!
That started out as a fake, like, sarcastic "oh, no"...
...and then it got asdfjkl--
Oh, nevermind. This is absolutely ridiculous.
Ooookay.
All right.
It doesn't exactly hurt...
...it's just as like...
...aahh, my hand is suddenly spamsing out of control.
Wh--yyy?
Oh, hey!
Sorry, I was in the middle something.
Were you trying to interrupt me?
I didn't mean to do that!
Hahh.
[pain]
"Well, maybe this isn't scary enough for you."
Oh, no, absolutely not.
"Do you know there's a giant spider behind this laptop?"
REALLY?!
"He really wants to meet you."
That's ... shocking!
Okay. All right. Okay.
My hands are like going numb.
I think I'm getting used to it.
Hello spider!
Where are you at?
EECH, all right!
Okkay.
[laughs]
God, this is ridiculous!
HELLO!
I'm trying not to let go and... goodness gravy.
Hello my little spider friend!
You wanna--don't wanna touch that hand yet...
...'cause you get shocked. ECH. ECH.
Ah. Oh, hello!
Hello!
Hope you guys can-- I hope...
...this is actually working...
...because I never tried a record setup...
...like this before.
This... oh, [pain noises].
I hear. I feel. I hear and feel.
EH!
[more pain noises] Okay.
Ah, you son of a bitch!
I know I played this before, but you're a son of a bitch!
Going into my braiiin!
NNNGNNGH. Okay.
Don't let go!
Ah, my fingers!
AH! Stop it!
[pain noises] STOP IT!
Why do I do this to myself?!
The worst part is...
...I have to do it to myself literally.
My keyboard is drifting away from me.
Come back keyboard! Plea--
Oookay. Oh, yeah, you.
Where's the button?
I lost the button!
There we go.
AAAH-kay. O-k-k-k-kay.
All right, you gonna do your little sword dance...
...and then I'm gonna try to hold on for my dear life!
Because I'm almost letting go. My fingers are tired.
[even more pain noises]
Hello.
I wonder if the battery is dying, because...
...it's either my hands are getting numb...
...or the battery in the machine is dying.
What kind of moron am I?!
Oh, yeah, I'm Markiplier!
That explains everything!
Why-why-why?
It's so... it's like totally different each time.
Yes, I know. I know. Hi. Hey.
ECH.
AH - it's like totally different each t-AH!
You son of a bitch!
EUGH! AAH!
Okay, that's enough of you!
Get out! Out of my ear! Out of my ear!
I turned the volume-AAH-way up louder
then I had it before.
[laugh and pain]
UHH. Stop it! Stop it! Stop it!
ECH. Stop it! [laughs]
"Okay. I give up. Congratulations!"
Cool.
"Guess you win. Weell, let me try one more thing."
You got a surprise me? Ookay.
Tingly fingers! Okay.
UUU, I wonder what that's all about!
OH NO!
GAH [laughs]
You bastard!
AAAH!
One more, for good measure!
Oookay. AH! Okay.
All right!
H-ooh...
[laughs]
This is what I do for a living!
This is ridiculous!
I GET TO DO THIS!
FOR FUN!
YAY!!!
Oh my god, okay.
So that was the electroshock challenge.
I didn't... like, I wanted to tone it back down...
...from the three point--
I'm sweating so much from that!
You can even see it!
It's all over me!
But either way...
Oooh, that was so much fun!
It was like... it wasn't... it wasn't painful.
I don't want people to worry like:
"Oh no, he's electrocuting himself!"
This is like a... this like a...
...teenager's game, so it's not exactly...
...a deadly volt of electricity.
I just had it and I wanted to play it, so...
...there you have it.
That was Don't Let Go, and I didn't let go! I didn't!
I did the challenge!
So if you enjoyed this video...
...and you enjoy these impossible let's plays...
...leave a like down below...
...and write in the comments...
...aaany other challenge you want me to do.
Maaaybe not hot sauce...
But aaany other challenge you want me to do.
I'm sooo open.
Go wild, go crazy!
Thank you all so much for watching!
And, as always,...
...I will see you...
...in the next video!
Bye-byeee!